alright here we are the future I'm Keith
the electric daredevil ready to try the
hourglass okay alright okay yep welcome
to the Future it's very terrifying oh I
can't go forward I'm stuck
oh well I'm spinning if the goal is to
spin I figure that one out all right
we got to do this that actually is
working is this supposed to go faster
ah one small step for man one giant step
for Ashlee kind I feel like to really
like go forward the way I want to I just
have to look solemn oh yeah I know
you're mad I'm mad too I'm so sad just
the saddest man on this tiny portable
lateral skateboard yeah I got this now I
feel pretty confident on it I don't like
the uneven terrain oh no can't slow down
live in New York and walking [ __ ]
sucked if I had one of these Dan you
give me those 20 blocks and I will board
oh I'm turning I'm turning I'm turning
I feel good I feel proud of myself that
I was able to make it to the gate and
back without falling off it probably
took me a lot longer than other people
but hey I did it I also feel really old
I mean the positive is when you have one
of these everybody knows you got money
it's like I was trying to hold on to a
tree with my legs the whole time except
the tree was moving around so I feel
really cool I feel a little bit
connected to today's youth hello you
I feel connect to see you maybe next
time you guys will invite me to sit with
you at bunny or not cool they're gonna
have to make new laws about this can i
play with it a little more this is cool
I also like being the best at it does it
go up hills